[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sail
israels herzlich willkommen
hogwarts heute traue ich mich
tatsächlich endlich an die harry potter
torte die letzten jahre habe ich
wirklich schon versprochen und ich
glaube bei mir hat sich schon so ein
bisschen im druck aufgebaut denn ich
glaube eure erwartungshaltung ist schon
ziemlich hoch
ich habe folgende situation ich möchte
terry porter torte machen die natürlich
thematisch gut dazu passt sie soll aber
auch gut schmecken das heißt ich mache
keine motiv torte die eben auch nach
machbar ist
ich meine es gibt tote künstler cache
decke raiders die einfach wochen lang an
der torte arbeiten die krassesten zucker
figuren machen aber so was kann man zum
einen zu hause nicht nachmachen und zum
anderen ist es halt irgendwann einmal
einfach nicht mehr essbar und genießbar
also mache ich eine torte die
hoffentlich euren erwartungen entspricht
ich nehme euch jetzt einfach mit denn
momentan weiß ich noch nicht so ganz
genau was nicht mache ich habe schon
eine kleine vorstellung aber ihr seht
schon werden muss schon mächtig ins zeug
gelegt das war alles ein bisserl in
harry potter reinkommen ich muss auch
dazu sagen ich habe die bücher nicht
gelesen bitte steinigt mich nicht ich
habe sie noch nicht gelesen
ich weiß noch als kind da war ich in der
fünften klasse ja so alt bin ich schon
1997 kam es erste buch raus und 99 haben
alle meine freunde das buch gelesen und
ich hab's nicht gekriegt also konnte ich
nicht lesen ich mich trifft keine schuld
aber irgendwann kam die filme die habe
ich dann geguckt wir waren sogar damals
in der nacht also im kino alle drei
filme nacheinander etwas gesteckt und ja
aber ich bin wirklich schon ein bisschen
aus dem thema raus aber josch und sarah
die sind voll die harry potter fans darf
ich das so sagen okay das nicht aber
sarah ich voll der freak murat habe ich
auch schon weg geschickt um paar asse so
was zu holen und die zwei die
helfen ein bisschen auf die sprünge ja
also ich habe mir jetzt vorgestellt ich
mache zum einen den sprechenden hut
der entscheidet ja darüber in welches
hausmann einziehen
dann mache ich eine mit sonne
dreistöckige torte werden
ich habe mir schon einiges hoffen um die
nächsten tage dann mache ich eine
mittlere torte die soll das harry potter
logo haben und so ein bisschen der beton
optik und das untere stockwerk da habe
ich mir gedacht auch in dem ich so ein
orientiere ich mich so ein bisschen an
gleis 9 drei viertel und macht das eben
noch ja und dann gucke ich einfach was
passiert und dann legen wir einfach los
als ich mach mir ein paar überlegungen
nehmen euch bisschen mit wie ich was
überlegen warum ich welche zutat nehme
oder wie ich die torte mache und dann
habe ich eine anleitung hoffe nicht ich
hoffe also die machen wir außen grau
dann ist hier gerade noch den goldenen
schnitts entweder sitzt er dann hier
oder stift das leck oder stift es auch
lehrer der straße noch aus meiner
schulzeit kann nun neu erstellte er ist
auch mehr mein gott
[Musik]
und diese torte mache ich jetzt mit
einem neuen geschmack und zwar apple
crumble da mache ich eine abfüllung ein
crumble dazu und eine passende
buttercreme ja und die der hut der wirt
aus schokolade
das passt am besten habe ich eine
schokotorte apfeltorte und da unten
mache ich jetzt gleich noch ein
dreiviertel da muss ich mir auch uns
bilder anschauen
[Musik]
dieser so ein bisschen rot braun von
außen und da fällt mir jetzt so könnt
ihr dieses kaugummi dieses scharfe von
trips mit zimt ich mache dieses amt über
oder haben wir das früher mal gekauft
das war so mit zimt und scharf und
dunkelrot ich glaube ich mache was mit
zimt und kirsch
das fällt mir so spontan ein zimt und
kirsch was packe ich denn zuerst das
wird ja ein jahrhundertprojekt also
zuerst einmal würde ich jetzt sagen rein
auszeit geht aus zeitlichen gründen
würde ich jetzt einfach die böden backen
bis 1 schoko böden hier und ich zeige
euch gleich was ich hier für böden mache
ich überlege mir kurzen tag und dann
geht's an die zutaten fahrt für den
schokoladenkuchen nämlich 320 gramm
butter 200 gramm bitterschokolade 200
gramm zucker und eine prise salz acht
eier 200 gramm mehl eineinhalb teelöffel
backpulver 30 gramm und etwas tun kann
das ist jetzt der schokoladenkuchen für
saftige motiv torten den nehm jetzt
nämlich für den hut damit ich den hut
einfach später schön form schneiden kann
ich habe bisher den zucker reduziert
denn die torte wird süß genug
jetzt nehme ich erst mal die butter die
kommt in den topf und kann schon mal
geschmolzen werden auf niedriger stufe
bitte in der schüssel hier kann ich
schon mal die eier verrühren
da gebe ich auch schon mal zucker und
ist als dazu anders war das kleine
zucker das großen ist für mich jetzt
schon mal hier findet sich gar nicht
schaumig gerührt sondern wirklich nur
verrührt das ganze ist nämlich kein
lockerer teig sondern eher ein fester
aber dafür ein saftiger und dadurch
lässt uns nicht eben später dann auch
gut in form schneiden was für
schokoholics sobald die butter dann
flüssig ist könnt ihr den herd
ausschalten und die schokolade dazugeben
und schmiss tische roulade nämlich in
der restwärme und die masse wird nicht
so heiß da kann ich sie nämlich gleich
weiter benutzen
das kann jetzt hier schon verschmelzen
ich kann hier die trockenen zutaten noch
verrühren bzw alle in ein sieb
hineinfühlen
alles geschmack
okay ich hatte einen topf mit einem
stillleben so na ja ich gebe es auch so
hinten und jetzt kommt diese warme masse
direkt zur masse deswegen dazu auch
nicht zu heiß sein sonst hat er nämlich
frei und hier passt halt jetzt echt
donckerwolke richtig gut dazu da kommen
hier einfach nur noch die trockenen
zutaten dazu und werden anstatt
eingerührt
[Musik]
wenn ich jetzt nur den sprechenden hut
als torte machen würde würde ich das
ganze etwas größer machen und einfach in
back ringend backen so habe ich nämlich
schon eine runde form
ich mache jetzt aber so der hut im
durchmesser bei mir jetzt 30 cm hat aber
nur dieser hass verschafft fassen dass
beim rothus dieses ding hier wollen wir
30 zentimeter im durchmesser haben und
der hut an sich oben 15 cm
ich habe es nämlich an dem bild so
ausgemessen proportional und die höhe
sondern auch 30
und so kleine back ringe habe ich nicht
also packe ich das ganze ist er in einem
backblech und steckst später einfach aus
und jetzt kann auch schon gebacken
werden während der kuchen im ofen ist
mache ich mich schon mal an den nächsten
kuchen das wird nämlich das zweite
stockwerk die harry potter dort
sozusagen diese beton optik da mache ich
jetzt einen wahllos kuchen und der wird
ja später mit apple crumble gefüllt
probier's einfach mal aus dafür nämlich
vier eier 200 gramm zucker eine prise
salz drei tropfen karamell aber jeweils
200 gramm butter milch und
sonnenblumenöl 130 gramm walnüsse die
mal ich gleich noch 300 gramm mehl und
zwei teelöffel backpulver und die
gleichen zutaten habe ich hier im
hintergrund noch mal denn ich mag das
ganze in einem 25 zentimeter ring und
ich will die torte schon etwas höher
haben deswegen mag ich jetzt einfach
gleich zwei bilden
und hier ist es auch wirklich super
einfach er gibt zuerst eier salz zucker
und karamell in eine rührschüssel
[Musik]
da karamell passt wirklich supergut dazu
und jetzt hier die zutaten einfach schön
cremig verrühren den ofen habe ich
bereits auf 170 grad ober unterhitze
vorgeheizt und im hintergrund ruhig
schon mal den zweiten tag auch nicht
[Musik]
da ist jetzt fertig der darf hier
abkühlen
der ofen ist bereit für den nächsten und
hier kommen jetzt die flüssigkeiten
rhein werden jetzt ganz kurz und
eingerührt und hier kann ich schon mal
backpulver und mehrere in mainz sieht
geben
es gebe ich hier noch die wahl müsste
rein
die mit fast aus der hand geflogen
werden mehl und backpulver und entdecken
und das wird jetzt nur noch ganz kurz
untergehoben bzw eingerührt und weil der
teig eben etwas flüssiger ist musste ich
die torten ringe einfach in bank papier
einschlagen der mediziner direkt
eingefüllt und weil eben die doppelte
menge für einen bug ring zu viel wäre
mache ich das eben auf zwei mal das
heißt hinten der eine tag hier der
andere teil
und natürlich dann einfach nacheinander
backen oder in zwei backöfen als in
einem backofen mit heißluft funktioniert
es nicht
da werden sie trocken und wenn ihr nur
einen habt macht sie wirklich schön
nacheinander
offen 1 offen 2 und danach geht es an
den dritten kuchen
[Musik]
weiter geht es jetzt mit dem dritten
kuchen das ist erzählt kuchen für den
zum teil nämlich fünf eier 250 gramm
zucker eine prise salz jeweils 250 gramm
sonnenblumenöl und buttermilch 500 gramm
mehl ein päckchen backpulver das sind
drei teelöffel und drei esslöffel zimt
und da bitte unbedingt darauf achten den
jones --im zu nehmen und nicht den
günstigen cassia zimt den günstigen
kasse jetzt sind darf man nämlich nicht
überdosieren und deswegen lieber tim
james ich probier's mal mit drei
esslöffeln vielleicht auch zu viel
ich probiere einfach später also das ist
jetzt die menge für einen 30 cm ring ich
habe hier hinten wieder die gleiche
menge so dass ich einfach zwei kuchen
backen kann
die zubereitung ist genau gleich wie
beim kuchen gerade eben eier zucker und
salz richtig schaumig rühren danach die
zwei flüssigkeiten dazu die trockenen
zutaten dazu alles unter rühren und
einfüllen
das sieht so richtig lecker nacht sind
klima
und das mittagessen für alle und zwar in
mediterranen nudelsalat metropolen legal
gemüsepfanne
ich habe noch immer voll rein und büros
der inder groß
apple
derzeit kann ja hier schon mal können
alle kuchen abbringen
alle hoffen
[Musik]
die kuren böden sind abgekühlt und ihr
wünscht euch ja immer für meine torten
besondere füllungen daher bekommt jetzt
auch jede torte eine andere füllung
jetzt fange ich zuerst mal mit dem hut
an
dafür verwende ich 100 gramm
zartbitterschokolade die habe ich
bereits aufgeteilt in zwei drittel ein
dritter 50 g gehackte mandeln und 50
gramm salzbrezeln schmelz jetzt zuerst
mal die zwei drittel kuvertüre und hier
kann richtig salzbrezeln verkleinern
wenn ihr keine einseitigen college in
der torte haben wollt könnt ihr auch
konflikt nehmen oder wenn ihr ganz auf
die arbeit verzichten und einfach schoko
grosny und sobald die zwei drittel
geschmolzen sind einfach vom wasserbad
herunternehmen und das restliche drittel
einrühren
so wird die kuvertüre einfach temperiert
das heißt wieder heruntergekühlt und sie
wird schon fest und glänzt und bekommt
keinen grauen schleier und damit alles
gemeinsam fort wir sollten einfach die
kompletten brezel mit der kuvertüre
schön umhüllt sein denn dann bleibt es
auch schön knackig und hier habe ich
jetzt ein kleines alu blech eine dauer
back folie drauf
das kommt jetzt hier drauf und darf dann
in den kühlschrank und ich kann in der
zwischenzeit schon mal die abfüllung
machen für die zweite tor
die abfüllung nämlich ein kilo äpfel da
habe ich jetzt elster äpfel geschehe
nicht auch gleich und messers gestellte
gewicht etwas vanille extract 30 gramm
stärke 20 gramm zucker 108 und den saft
einer zitrone die äpfel schälen
entkernen schnallt sie dann in würfel
und mit der apfel schale könnt ihr zum
beispiel den richtig leckeren absolute
macht einfach mit heißem wasser
übergießen und dann entweder süßen oder
nichts wissen
so wie es euch am besten schmeckt bei
den äpfeln habe ich jetzt doch nur 600
gramm genommen denn ich glaube das wird
ansonsten einfach zu viel ich will ja
noch crumble machen als ob hier kommen
jetzt noch der zitronensaft dazu damit
die äpfel nicht braun werden und auch
für die säure und dann kann ich jetzt
hier die stärke mit dem apfelsaft
verrühren
[Musik]
es kommt dann auch hier dazu und etwas
war ein extrakt sind wer mag noch ein
bisschen zucker die masse könnt ihr hier
auf dem herd einfach so ein bisschen
aufkochen lassen und einkochen lassen
bis die äpfel etwas weich werden
ich gebe da es am anfang noch ein deckel
gleich drauf und kann in der
zwischenzeit auch schon mal die kirsch
füllung machen würden dritten kuchen
schmeckt lecker für die kirche stellung
nehme ich 300 gramm kirschen aus dem
tiefkühlfach 50 ca 20 gramm stärke und
20 gramm wasser
die kirschen habe ich jetzt bereits
auftauen lassen und tricks in seiner
aber größtenteils hoffe ich schon mal
aufgetaucht
die peri ich jetzt mit dem zucker und
wasser was ich auch sehr große tabu
[Musik]
stärk kommt auch gleich dazu
und wenn ihr gefrorene kirchen nimmt
habt ihr wirklich diese wunderschöne
farbe nicht wie die aus dem glas
es kommen die zehn top darf auch auf
kochen ist es ein bisschen einlegt und
dann habe ich schon die dritte wohnung
fertig dafür nehme ich 100 gramm butter
100 gramm zucker eine prise salz und 200
g mehl und wenn ihr möchtet noch
karamell aroma und das ganze verknetet
ihr einfach mit den händen
jetzt kurz durchkneten zu streuseln und
dann kann ich jetzt schon mal in der
zwischenzeit die butter krems zu
bereiten
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr auch eine
garage machen für die einzelnen torten
ist ein bisschen einfacher weil der
kanal schnur aus sahne und schokolade
besteht aber ich muss euch eins sagen
meine mutter krems schmecken wirklich
nicht so puttrich sondern eher
schokoladig oder fruchtig je nachdem wie
man sie eben zubereitet und ich glaube
bei den meisten stoffe allen drei mache
ich jetzt gleich eine buttercreme
vielleicht entscheide ich mich noch
spontan um aber ich fange schon mal
damit an und die streusel könnte jetzt
so direkt aufs blech geben
hier sind die zutaten für die schoko
buttercreme für den sprechenden hut der
milch den sprechenden hut sehe dann ist
er für mich innen und außen schoko pur
da freut sich damals ja sechs eier 200
gramm zucker und halben teelöffel salz
450 g weiche butter 300 gramm
zartbitterschokolade und tom kawara
mensch dass du nicht mehr schlafen
müssen bei der butter ich bin ein sehr
guter reiche haushalte die torte nicht
allein die ista marcel also bei der
butter kleben ist jetzt ganz wichtig
dass die eier mit dem zucker und salz
erhitzt werden auf 70 grad entweder
nehmen wir dafür einen topf gestellt
eine schüssel drüber und unten drunter
natürlich wasser also ein wasserbad
lasst es wasser kochen und rührt und mit
dem handrührgerät die eier zucker master
für zehn minuten dann ist er wirklich
auch schon schön erhitzt oder ihr nehmt
eine küchenmaschine etc funktion
ich wünsche euch jetzt wirklich super
gerne auf dem herz zeigen aber ich habe
noch so viel vor und ich bin heute
irgendwann noch fertig werden zumindest
mit erfüllung dass ich das jetzt hier
direkt bei 70 grad macht also hier
butter eier zucker und salz sind die
rührschüssel und dann verrühren
hier auf 70 grad und da muss es auch
gleich aufpassen denn bei 60 grad kommt
zu diese schutzfunktion dann wird die
maschine langsamer
denn es könnte ja sein dass ein kind
kommt und die maschine auf volle pulle
dreht und dann einfach heißer masse
heraus spritzte und deswegen hat die
eine schutzfunktion
das heißt bei 60 grad hitze langsam
lebens dann einfach mit bestätigen hallo
ich bin an der maschine früher ruhig
weiter und dann kann ich auch noch auf
vier rühren und in der zwischenzeit die
schokolade in der mikrowelle schnellem
fahren heute der tag wird noch lang und
morgen und ich habe auch keine deko und
ich denke gerade so war habe ich mir da
eigentlich nur angetan
warum guckst du so böse
haha sitzt einfach da in der ecke und
trägt nichts zur tour dabei ich habe
helle und dunkle stroese durch denn ich
habe große und kleine sondern
gleichmäßig bräunen hier schon mal jetzt
die platte raus lösen
[Musik]
und zwar etwas uneben gebacken aber das
wird gleich ausgelöst
es kommt hier schonmal tonga war noch
rein geben tonka und schokolade sind für
die papier und pappe mit ins training
[Musik]
noch 5 minuten und dann schalte ich die
hitze ab und lass es wieder kalt wird
und dann dann in der zwischenzeit schon
mal die butterweichen
[Musik]
wenn das land werde erzählt anna
zuckermasse wieder kalt gerührt also
handwarm schokolade das geschmolzene
butter ist auch schön cremig jetzt füge
ich einfach alles zusammen das heißt
alles linie in die schüssel
[Musik]
und diese eier zucker butter grundmasse
nehme ich auch gleich für die anderen
torten
nur kommt da dann keine schokolade rein
da überlege ich was reinkommt aber jetzt
machen wir erstmal hier die hut torte
und ich kann dann parallel immer wenn
ich was zum kühlen habe einfach die
anderen cremes hören von der konsistenz
ist jetzt so schön cremig und die
futterstelle hält sich auch ein paar
tage hier könnt ihr auch im kühlschrank
aufbewahren kann wieder rausholen auf
zimmertemperatur kommen lassen noch mal
kurz cremig rühren und dann nochmal
weiterverarbeiten
wenn wir mächtig ich will sie mit nur um
weil mir das papier zu groß ist und dann
film weiß schon mal die hut torte ich
glaube das sagt so die von der form her
aufwendigste torte kann ich meine
eigenen songs meine stimme schön hier
meinen eigenen songs zusammen stellen ok
jetzt fühlen wir den hut also wir machen
den tod ich nehme da gerne so eine
antirutschmatten dann kommt da einen
garching bot drauf und wie gesagt da hat
dann hut jetzt nicht so mega groß wird
wie ist bei einer alleinstehenden torte
und die proportionen stimmen soll mache
ich den hut 15 cm im durchmesser
ich habe jetzt hier leider nur 14
das heißt ich schneid den ersten mit
einem messer
dann sprechen wir erst einmal zwei aus
und da
kurztrips schneidig heilung zu der etwas
größer ist
[Musik]
dann nehme ich jetzt einfach keine
ausstecher noch
[Musik]
ich nasche aus kuchenteig das mag
und sie ausprobieren was man macht
aber dadurch dass ich jetzt nicht heute
fertig mit der torte und sie nicht heute
verzerrt wird werde ich die böden noch
mit espresso trinken damit sie schön
saftig bleiben
das ausstechen
[Musik]
machst du vielleicht mit mir ein roboter
bauen ein roboter ist ein roboter bauen
zu zweit okay den kuchen tags du mit ok
wenn das so kommt das ist ein roboter
bauen war es noch ganz viel spaß danke
danke
ja wir teilen uns das
[Musik]
jetzt trinke ich den kuchen einfach mit
espresso also wenn ihr keine nespresso
rückt könnt ihr auch milch nehmen oder
zucker sirup oder rum oder gegen das
andere ok und dann kommt jetzt bisschen
buttercreme drauf perfekt sarah hat die
harzer mensch brauche ich gleich mal das
presse und fans habe ich ja hier diese
klischees die kommen dann hier rein und
so werde ich jetzt die torte stapeln ich
muss auch gleich noch einen staat holen
damit die torte auch schön hält da warte
ich noch mal ein bisschen creme drauf
dann kann sie auch zwischendurch mal
kühlen
denn bei mir ist jetzt die buttercreme
etwas weich aber das ist schön
sarrazin ich mache eine harry potter
torte also den anfangen würde ich schon
so gerade machen und dann nach oben
das machen wir dann aber mit
marshmallows nicht dass sie dann einen
partner
das kommt es im kühlschrank ich nehme
hier einen stapel rundholz 0 5 mm und
den schneide ich jetzt 25 zentimeter zu
lang zu das ist hier denn kann so das
festhalten schatz denn der hut wird ihr
nach oben hin geboren
ich mache ist das achte schritt das so
an und dann bricht durch und der kommt
jetzt hier rein und jetzt starte ich
einfach noch so lange wie ich eben auch
creme und tortenböden habe
und den rest mache ich aus marshmallow
und das kommt jetzt hier aber erstmal in
den kühlschrank oder vielleicht sogar in
die krieg gedroht da geht es sind
schneller wieder schneller fest guckt
mal die zwischen mücken hier die kann
ich noch kurz ausfüllen und dann den
kühlschrank stellen denn dann ist er
hier schon mal fest der kuchen
ich bin so eine umfrage starten wir
wieder am freitag spontan mit einer
reporter toto heiraten werden sie als
hochzeitstorte es gibt da papa joe mein
bester freund
die kommt jetzt in die gefriertruhe
machst du mir auf wenn sie noch ein fast
und der höhe
aber gerade so weiter gehts mit der
zweiten tochter als zweites stockwerk da
habe ich ja schon die beiden bilden
vorgebackenen das crucible afl die apfel
masse ist im kühlschrank und da mache
ich jetzt auch die buttercreme dann
nehme ich einfach die gleiche menge also
sechs eier 200 gramm zucker etwas salz
450 gramm weiche butter und für das
aroma einfach etwas karamell und ein
bisschen zitronen abruf und die
zubereitung ist hier die gleiche wie bei
der schoko creme dh die eier werden mit
dem zucker und dem salz bei 70 grad etwa
zehn minuten erwärmt und gleichzeitig
schaumig gerührt
danach nehmen die hitze weg und die eier
masse wird dann kalt gerührt die butter
kann dann in der zwischenzeit schon mal
cremig gerührt werden
und dann gebe ich nur noch karamell und
zitrone dazu und für alles zusammen
solange die kinos ist kann ich jetzt
erst mal die karten würden häufig nicht
nur parallel auch schon die dritte
buttercreme als er geht hier heißt so
denn kubon vorankommen
ich bin zwei torten immer mega wichtig
dass die tortenböden schön dünn sind
denn damit die tore einfach besser wie
wir mal einen dicken kuchen
wenn man so eine dicke schichten hat
also immer schön führung dazwischen
schlägt auch für abwechslungsreiche er
zwar ein bisschen mehr arbeit damit das
lohnt sich selten sind sie jetzt kann
ich noch schnell die buttercreme
zusammenfügen und dann die torte füllen
in dieser buttercreme gebe ich jetzt
lege sagt etwas karamell was sie hier
auch ganz gut nehmen könnt sind diese
karamellbonbons die könnt ihr
einschmelzen mit der passage zum
beispiel und dann dazu geben
eine prise zitronen april waren meine
stimme grab bringen egal
und hier jetzt die butter wenn ja es ist
alles brutal
die haben wir die tore nicht alleine
marcel ist auch mit und sehr mag
nur dennis und volkan nicht wirklich
vegan
[Musik]
ich sag's euch dass ich wirklich
kräfteraubend
sie ist eingefroren gut es gibt
schlimmeres schlimmer wäre es wenn die
torte nicht fest wird jetzt nämlich ein
25 zentimeter gamaschen bord da kommt
der erste obendrauf
manchmal ziehen sich tiger nach dem
backen zusammen deswegen ist es dann
immer tut wenn ihr die gleiche größe
einstellt wie das garagen bord dieser
mandl rührkuchen lässt sich allerdings
fast nie zusammen also da könnt ihr
gerne den tortenring 5 mm kleine
einstellen ich zeige euch später warum
damit wird das garagentor zum füllen
benutzen können ok und jetzt wird das
ganze gefüllt mit der karamell
zitronencreme dann die apfel füllung
[Musik]
jetzt fühle ich jetzt auch noch etwas
creme ein dahinter drängen und damit
kann ich jetzt eine umrandung hier drauf
spritzen
die mieter noch mittel auffüllen dann
kommen jetzt noch die gesamte drauf
[Musik]
und da der nächste boden und so finde
ich jetzt die ganze torte und schließt
damit einen schönen glatten boden ab und
wenn ihr das gefühl habe die torte ist
zur wahl stellt sie einfach kurz ins
gefrierfach oder in den kühlschrank und
füllt dann eben erst weiter
zur letzte schicht das ist alles wieder
perfekt abgemessen
kommt her ja natürlich
wer arbeitet kommt muss auch einmal
wegen harry potter torte hätte den
letzten streichen
das ist sich jetzt schon also ich
überlege jetzt schon wer ich nehme es
ihnen speisen alle grüßen
ich will jetzt schon wer die torte alles
essen sollen und jetzt wie gesagt der
boden als abschluss und ich finde es
hier echt schön dass es eine hohe trotte
ist denn dann kann ich den rand auch
schön dekorieren aber kontrolle
und dann leg ich hier den torten retter
drauf und der torten waage perfekt und
die torte darf jetzt über nacht in den
kühlschrank und darf auskühlen und erst
werden
ich werde jetzt nur noch damit sie
einfach am rand auch schon mal schön
gerade wird also ich könnte sie auch so
im kühlschrank packen aber einpacken
damit einfach nicht nach kühlschrank
richtig mache sich so oder so ich legen
tortenring außen rum und damit ich den
wieder ganz einfach weg bekommen ohne
jetzt großartig mit importen matter
mache ich ja noch wachs papier außenrum
backpapier geht aber auch und so habe
ich sie zum einen vor gerüchten
geschützt und zum anderen wird so schön
stabil und eben auch schon mal verraten
ich glaube ich muss den extra hohen
drücken jetzt tatsächlich ein bisschen
zusammen dass er etwas kleiner ist als
25 so kann ich ihnen morgen und dann
nehme ich mir gut durch gefühlt ist
schön gerade an den seiten bestreichen
text jetzt hier auch noch ab und damit
so schön luftdicht verschlossen hat
heute 2 hess gefüllt jetzt kommt torte 3
okaz
das gleiche spiel jetzt auch bei der
neuen drei viertel torte die z boden
einfach durchschneiden und da habe ich
jetzt auch schon die buttercreme gerührt
den ersten würden läge hierarchie traum
jetzt kann ich hier auch die buttercreme
fertigstellt so erst einmal dhkp c die
weiche butter die eier masse und ich
nehme es nochmal zimt ist eine schöne
zimt kirschtorte werden jetzt mag ich
aber ich will jetzt auch folgender
spülmaschinen schon parallel hier ist
echt immer wichtig dass diese eier maße
schön abgekühlt wird
das tier wieder kalt gerührt wird
ansonsten schmilzt nämlich die butter
und dann habt ihr keine buttercreme
sondern sondern flüssige klingen wenn es
doch mal passiert einfach kurz im
kühlschrank geben und dann eben noch mal
schön
und ich sehe doch die wir erstmal noch
mal flüssiger und allem ist es einfach
rühren die ganze zeit mit der
küchenmaschine machen
sie wird dann wieder stellung gehen sie
mithalten wir schon wenn du dir jetzt
auch so und ich hier mache ich jetzt so
dass ich zuerst die böden mit starken
schmerzen bestreichen und die torte dann
mit der film scream gefühle
[Musik]
die 1 gewonnen
sie wird ihre
was sie möchten wir die uhrzeit und
jetzt hier den rand noch schön machen
hier kommt jetzt auch etwas papier
drumherum ein toppen ring ein deckel
drauf und dann kommen die torte in der
küche
ich muss euch eins sagen die
marshmallows spitze mache ich heute
nicht mehr das machen wir morgen
wir fangen wir damit an jetzt wird auf
der bank morgen geht es weiter
kann dem antrag gar nicht mehr mit multi
menge ist für die weiße schokolade und
das für die kleine das mache für das ok
ok also ich mach jetzt eine ganz guten
morgen heute ist der nächste tag und
zwar mache ich einmal weiße garage und
eine vollmilch genascht und damit werden
dann die torten später glatt gestrichen
ihr könnt auch mehr buttercreme machen
aber die garage wird immer ein bisschen
fester und dann ist es arbeiten
einfacher weil gar nicht so schnell
schmilzt wie buttercreme gemacht so lang
ok sehr gut und für die gala schreibt
ihr einfach die schokolade fein oder ihr
aktiv einkocht sahne auf und dann rührt
er alles miteinander kann sprich auch
ein hin
wir üben jetzt die aussprache sack sagt
wie heißt das falsche wort
nein wir üben jetzt alles zusammenpasste
pascha brachte sehr gut
und normalerweise schreibe ich die
schokolade auch mal so per hand aber
jetzt habe ich wirklich sehr viel
schokolade und ich mag das eine große
menge weil ich noch nicht weiß wie viele
gar nicht brauchen werde
aber ich kann sie einfrieren wenn ich
sie nicht komplett brauchen und dann
habe ich das nächste mal schon danach
stellt sich eigentlich übrigens immer
sondern wir machen immer was nebenher
was anderes entweder frühstück oder
mittag immer multitasking also wenn ihr
öfter einen blick hinter die kulissen
haben wollt dann sagt einfach bescheid
wir machen auch gleich hefeteig werden
heute mittag jetzt pizza habe ich es
noch gar nicht gesagt
in jeder kannte sich belegen offenbar
seinen kindergeburtstag
also ich werde jetzt hier die sahne
einmal hier auf kochen für die große
menge denn so eine große rutsche so habe
ich nicht und dann habe ich noch die
andere sache für die dunkle ganache für
die vollmilch und wie heißt es ach
fädeln super gar natürlich voll schon
ein getürkt
[Musik]
so die sahne ist gedacht schaffe ich es
ohne kleckern
[Musik]
und jetzt höre ich sie hier weiter
natürlich ohnehin denn die hinter der
same reicht schon aus
und sobald diese garage jetzt auch
berührt ist und schön geschmeidig ist
denke ich sie ab ich fühle aber in drei
portionen ab dann könnt ihr nämlich
schneller ab lasse bei raumtemperatur
oder ganz ganz kurz im kühlschrank fest
werden bisher streichfähig ist und mache
jetzt direkt mit dem hut weiter da kommt
nämlich marshmallows crespi drauf
ja
ich hoffe wir brauchen nicht die ganze
bagage das war schon heftig jetzt geht's
mit der hut torte weiter ich habe hier
ein bild für mich was ich hier
hersteller und da oben möchte ich jetzt
diese spitze formen
das heißt ich brauche jetzt marshmallows
und reis christie's die habe ich jetzt
eins zu eins das heißt 200 gramm
marshmallows zweier kameras christie's
rund 20 gramm butter und die
marshmallows werden jetzt in der
mikrowelle geschmolzen oder in der
pfanne aber mikrowelle ist hier wirklich
viel viel einfacher
[Musik]
da sind sie jetzt die weichen
marshmallows sie sehen nicht heiß aus
aber glaubt mir sie sind super heiß da
kommt jetzt die butter rein
die schmelz darin also nicht mit den
fingern rein das wirklich heißen
zuckermasse und hier jetzt die schoko
christie's rein und das ist wirklich zum
einen super lecker und zum anderen kann
man es wirklich benutzen um alles
mögliche zu formen
und jetzt fertig meine hände jetzt
gibt's auch nicht mehr so heiß sein
das heißt ihr könnt sie jetzt nehmen und
die mache dann einfach schön kneten
aber ist wirklich super lecker da gibt
es doch einen amerika einen müsliriegel
oder hals und schokoriegel
[Musik]
habe ich hier diese masse und meine
vorlage den hut ich habe mir einfach ein
bild aus dem film so aus dem internet
genommen
ich habe extra ein bisschen mehr gemacht
aber die menschen haben kann man jetzt
so ein bisschen zusammendrücken
so jetzt kompakter
[Musik]
und ich habe gesehen dass die torte und
doch noch ein bisschen breiter ist das
heißt kann es hier auch einfach diese
rechtlichen strenge nehmen und unten
noch dran kleben
gerade hier so ein bisschen ich habe
jetzt hier nochmal buttercreme unten an
den rand gestrichen wie ist ok aber ich
bilde das passt damit diese nur stimmig
wir wollten ja mit dem backstage zeigen
wie wir alles machen das machen wir mal
fotos videos alles parallel und ich
liebe diesen hut weil er einfach so
keine form hat also da können wir
wirklich nichts falsch machen
ich gucke jetzt noch mal die augen
müssten ungefähr hierhin ja der rote
augen
hier machen wir noch so eine mini nase
hier so eine erhöhung für die nase aber
wisst ihr was sie als nächstes machen
wir uns diesen sprechenden baum von
öfter ling dieser märchen baum
den mache ich
und jetzt hier unten der mond und man
darf vor dem mund reden kann die krümel
aus meinem leben heraus nicht verstehen
man hier ja ich muss die mit den dicken
packen ihn folie einpacken
ich muss erstmal fest werde und da unten
noch so dem mund so nur die
grundstruktur den rest mache ich dann
mit garagen kuchen bröse und so weiter
[Musik]
wenn es voll auf den der alten wohnung
gemacht das war so unser highlight dass
das video mit dem er gut erinnert mich
an irgendjemanden der auch so
augenbrauen hat niemand von hier gut
abgedeckt und wenn das hier oben nicht
hält könnt ihr einfach ein bisschen
frischhaltefolie nehmen und das
drumherum wickeln aber jetzt so langsam
hält eigentlich knicks noch ein bisschen
ab so passt berichtet für uns machen zu
regeln nicht noch eins kugeln und jetzt
kommt die torte in den kühlschrank und
wird dann gleich mit der garage
überzogen die sollte streichfähig seien
zwei stück
so ist jetzt hier gerade der
zwischenstand der hut hat schon seine
strukturen die beiden sind gefüllt und
richtig gut über nacht durch gekühlt und
die garage kühlt jetzt kam noch ein
bisschen aber jetzt kann ich im prinzip
diese zwei trotten schon mal mit garage
überziehen und da mache ich jetzt
einfach so ich mache eine erste schicht
drauf die hier diese krümmel bindet
diese lücken ausfüllt stellt sie dann
den kühlschrank und danach streicht das
sind noch mal richtig glaubt also jetzt
bei step die kommen den kühlschrank die
kommt auch in new york mit der kleinen
lege ich los und so benutze ich das gas
lng bord um die torte am rand hier
richtig schön glatt zu bekommen und das
ganze wirklich in ganz wenigen schritten
also das bekommt wirklich jeder hin
ich werde jetzt aber wie gesagt zuerst
einmal hier den rand mit ghanas
bestreichen damit hier diese krümel
einfach nicht mehr abfallen und dafür
nämlich jetzt die ghana stehen noch
nicht ganz so fest ist noch nicht
streichfähig lässt er sich nämlich
besser verteilen
aber für die nächste schickt für die
glatte schicht muss die garage auf jeden
fall streichfähig sein sonst könnt ihr
euch das der herr dann kommt die nächste
schicht drauf in den kühlschrank
ich war gerade einen zauberstab lagen
zwar im juli wanders und da habe ich dir
erschafft geholt jack russel hält heinz
wagner vom dumbledore warum nicht herr
wird er im angebot war der hat nur die
hälfte kostet so oliver ross heißt der
laden könnte die zauberschläge holen
kennt jemand noch lilo wanders das ist
es wichtig stets david schneller wenn es
damit schneller geht's mir echt der
wahnsinn oder
ja also lieber anders lilo wanders die
probleme aus atis temporis habe ich
geglaubt matte explosions spruch baum
bader maximal es hat geklappt
mal gucken was mit damit noch so alles
wünschen kann
die glatte torte kommt jetzt in den
kühlschrank da darfst du noch mal ein
bisschen durch kühle und ich mache die
anderen torten schön glatt und dann geht
es gleich weiter auf der hut der hut
kannst du auf den mut machen dann kann
ich euch ja nicht zeigen wie es
funktioniert
ok den hut machen wir selber sehen dass
man nicht zaubern hier sitzt die
mittlere torte also die harry potter
torte die beton optik apple grübelt ort
so jetzt habe ich sie und jetzt wird es
sehr glatt gestrichen ich nehme jetzt
einfach ein zweites cushing bord und das
hat ja 25 cm im durchmesser und da jetzt
einfach drauf achten dass es schön im
rechten winkel hierauf liegt also nicht
zu weit drüber
und jetzt werden diese lücken hier
einfach mit der übrigen ganache
aufgefüllt und so wird der rand schön
glatt
[Musik]
tritt auch großzügiger auftragen
und wenn ihr sie dann großzügig
aufgetragen habt nehmt ihr jetzt diese
große teig karte setzt sich hier an und
zieht den rest weg
und ich kühe die torte jetzt damit die
ganache hier fest wird dann kann ich
hier noch einmal die lücken ausfüllen
und nochmal einmal schön glatt abziehen
wird immer schwerer
es ist der sache überhaupt nicht gut
wenn ich der dumbledore ist auch nicht
der dumbledore zauberstab guck dir dann
zum jahre tableau herrscht reis das ist
sowas von falsch wie heißt der
zauberstab nimbus 2000 gewesen das von
harry 2000 stimmen muss 2000 gewesen
das ist der besen und die haben sich
veräppelt morath kannst zurückgeben
als kind habe ich es einfach nicht
verstanden wenn meine schwester wollte
immer nie dass ich das lied singen sie
streiten hier ein thema das raus was man
ja ich gebe ihn zurück sparbetrag hab
ich mal beim who hat abgesagt
guck mal ich zeige euch mal hier ein
unterschied und zwar habe ich ja die
garage in zwei behälter abgefüllt
hier ist sie noch flüssig und hier ist
ja schon fast zu fest aber ich benutze
beide denn an manchen stellen brauche
ich jetzt hier diese festere und ihr
könnte auch mit der palette einfach so
ein bisschen rein rühren und dann wird
die ja schon geschmeidig schon streich
fest und die die etwas flüssiger
verbrauche ich dann zum richtigen
glätten
das passt so schon ganz gut und wenn sie
euch mal wirklich zu fest ist kurz in
der mikrowelle oder über ein wasserbad
und er könnte sie benutzen und reste
wirklich einfach immer nur einfrieren
und auftauen
das klappt wunderbar es liegt jetzt
wirklich einfach nur daran die war nicht
im kühlschrank die war im kühlschrank
punkt kann man so geschmeidig und die
temperatur macht eben auch diesen
farbunterschiede als zwar ein und
dieselbe ganache ok mit der gage und
daher habe ich sie jetzt auch gemacht
kann ich jetzt hier die torte glätten
beziehungsweise die wenig kann halt so
gut wie instagram wird jetzt eh nicht
ganz glatt sondern ich finde es hier im
prinzip alles aus und der hut der hat er
schon wissen der schöne struktur und
durch diese falten entsteht das gesicht
und das probiere ich jetzt hier mit der
palette und
[Musik]
jetzt bekommen das gesicht nach mehr
struktur
das heißt ihr nehmt jetzt diese kann ab
jetzt auch dieser spitze palette dies
vorne woran gestützt die spitze und
damit könnt ihr wirklich diese schönen
gesichtszüge machen gesichtszüge mut
[Musik]
hier setzt sich jetzt gerade noch die
kuchen reste daran einfach überall da wo
ich denk da passt noch ein gesichts
druck hin
denn gerade jetzt zum beispiel war es
mir zu wenig dann nehme ich einfach den
kuchen rest und noch etwas buttercreme
dies nämlich weiter als kanal und damit
lässt sich nämlich besser ankleben
wie so eine art cake pops masse wird es
dann so bisschen zerbröselt vermischt
und guckt mal dann hält es schön
ansonsten wenn ihr sagt immer stimmt es
einfacher machen können ja auch marzipan
nehmen und einfach marzipan strenge
hinmachen geht wirklich viel einfacher
dem ist einfach nur modulieren und
ankleben oder modelle schokolade aber so
habe ich einfach eine leckere masse
drunter und nicht einfach so eine
schicht marzipan
[Musik]
die torte ist jetzt schon fest sie ist
noch nicht im wasser also noch nicht
ausgeglichen aber das passt ich nehme es
gerne an bord weg und es kann an bord
das besteht aus polycarbonat ist
lebensmittelecht und es ist ein wirklich
bruch sicheres material
[Musik]
hier kommt jetzt eine ganze schicht
drauf zum glätten
jetzt sind alle trocken glatt gestrichen
die größte arbeit ist getan wollte ich
gerade sagen aber das stimmt nicht er
kommt ja noch aber die grundbausteine
sind schon mal gesetzt und jetzt hab ich
mir überlegt dass sich die torte gleis 9
drei viertel mit grau über ziel und dann
backsteine drauf machen und die mittlere
torte überzählig grau und die wird so
eine beton optik haben und jetzt mache
ich aber erstmal die große torte also
die neuen drei viertel
ich habe ich jetzt weißen fondant das
ist eine zucker über zugs masse und dem
kann ich jetzt mit schwarzem fondant
vermischen
ich probiere es erst mal ein kleines
stückchen schwarz damit ich ein helles
grau erhalte
[Musik]
ich wollte halt noch zum sport aber das
war ich mir heute
ich glaube ich kann jetzt noch so ein
paar kniebeugen machen und dann habe ich
mal wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr die hände
mit etwas kokosfett oder kokosöl eben
einfetten
[Musik]
jetzt brauche ich erstmal nur einen teil
für die große torte denn von dort
wirklich immer schön lange durchkneten
damit er geschmeidig ist durch die hand
wärme wird er nämlich schön warm und
wenn er doch mal zu kalt ist einfach
kurz in der mikrowelle stellen nicht so
lange damit nicht trocknet also das kann
mal kurz weg packen und jetzt soll ich
denen einfach auf becker stärker aus
becker stärke ist kartoffelstärke und
die klub nicht also da jetzt wirklich
keine speisestärke benutzen denn da
bleiben dann rückstände und bei der
bäcker strecke bleiben keine und by
modus sogar kann es passieren dass er
von dort anfängt zu kleben und so habt
ihr die probleme einfach nicht ganz
rolle ich das schön dünn aus bei der
gleis 9 3 findet heute wirklich extrem
dünn denn da kommt ja dann noch eine
schicht von dann drauf durch die
backsteine und dann habt ihr nicht so
eine alte dicke schicht und wenn ihr
mehr luft blättchen habt so wie hier
könnte die aufstechen vorsichtig die
luft raus streichen und dann einfach
drüber rollen
jetzt bespricht die torte mit etwas back
trance train damit er vom dankeschön
haftet ansonsten ist er nämlich die
garage ist einfach trocken und davon
dann wird nicht haften
und jetzt hier die von der decke
entweder auf rollen oder auf den arm
hochnehmen und dann über die torte legen
dann hätte ich mir erstmal die
oberfläche hat damit die luft hier an
den seiten entweichen kann
hier ist das noch eine luftblase aber
das nicht schlimm denn ist sowieso das
unterste stockwerk und jetzt hier in
eine hand gedrückt oder glättet ihr denn
von dampf und die andere zieht denn hier
weg und so kann man eben diese falten
einfach weg streichelt schon da ist auch
gar nicht so richtig ich habe ihn
wirklich ganz lange durchgeknetet und
daher ist mit cher butter das heißt da
ist allgemein einfach nicht so richtig
und dann kann man da wirklich schön
lange modellieren ohne dass an der seite
was einreist
die rest durch schneide ich jetzt hier
weg und kann sie dann auch wieder
zusammen kneten und für die andere torte
benutzen und luftdicht verpackt könnt
ihr von dort übrigens mehrere wochen
aufbewahren da passiert nichts jetzt
nehme ich meine zwei klettern die letzte
erst mal die oberfläche ich weiß worauf
erwartet dr
kann ich okay 300 volt ich habe so viele
kredite an bauträger wie sie den
patienten getötet
[Musik]
mein team ist jetzt ähnlich so perfekt
sein da kommen die backsteine aus warum
aber ich habe gerne dass meine torten
perfekt ok dann kann die torte jetzt in
den kühlschrank
und weil ich immer gefragt werde wie
lange sich fondant orten halten das
kommt zum einen natürlich auf die
füllung an
ich habe jetzt hier eine füllung mit
kirschen und buttercreme das hält sich
schon vier bis fünf tage
und sobald ihr diese von dann schicht
drauf hat habt ist es einfach so wie so
eine art decke und ummantelung die
einfach die torte vor der außenwelt
schützt dadurch bleibt sie einfach ein
bisschen haltbar und sie trocknet eben
nicht aus wenn ich jetzt aber eine quark
sahne füllung habe dann würde ich die
schon innerhalb von zwei tagen essen
aber die hier die könnte ich jetzt schon
locker so zwei drei tage noch
aufbewahren da passiert nichts im
kühlschrank natürlich erst kommt
wirklich immer so ein bisschen auf die
spülung an eine sachertorte zum beispiel
die könnte dann sieben tag aufbewahren
sondern ganze woche passiert nichts ihr
dürft jetzt nur nicht folgenden fehler
machen also die torte kommt so in den
kühlschrank ohne abdeckung da ja jetzt
praktisch der von damit die abdeckung
ist und da jetzt wirklich keine schüssel
mehr außenrum machen ansonsten schwizer
von dann und dann geht die torte schon
kaputt also optisch nicht alleine tragen
das mache luftbläschen jetzt strecke bei
dieser torte habe ich jetzt ein von land
ausgerollt und etwa zehn minuten liegen
lassen damit er an trocknet denn ich
möchte eine beton optik sowie hier an
meiner wand und das ist ja auch ich
meine es ist nicht richtig sondern das
sind eher luftlöcher die entstehen wenn
man eben diese folie an die wand drückt
aber ich will so ein bisschen rissig
haben ein paar löcher haben ich rolle
jetzt nochmal drüber in der hoffnung
dass er reist kleidern von dann nicht so
reist ein nachteil dieses mal aber seht
ihr es dass so ein bisschen an
getrocknet und wenn ich jetzt noch
drüber gehe weder rissig ich hoffe dass
sie dann auch gewollt gut aus ich
probier's einfach vielleicht da noch so
ein bisschen
und dann machen wir da gleich eine coole
struktur rein hier jetzt auch ein
bisschen back trance prey damit davon
land haftet beim sprühen übrigens immer
darauf achten die flasche aufrecht zu
halten wenn ihr nämlich so markt oder so
dann entweicht das gas aber es kommt
dann kein öl aus und jemand habt ihr
dann nur noch das öl drin und kein gas
mehr
das öl kommt dabei raus es wird eben
nicht mehr so fein gesprüht und es
wirklich ein reines kokos und rapsöl und
da ist einfach so ein trip mittel drin
dass es eben aus der flasche rauskommt
jetzt hoffe ich zum ersten mal das heißt
es gab es auch noch nicht installiert
sind
aber ich sehe schon der hat schon so
eine leder optik und jetzt schön die
luft aus streichen und dann glatt
streichen
und die können jetzt aber wieder
zusammen kneten und beim nächsten mal
weiter benutzen denn so angetrocknet so
sehr an gedruckt und was jetzt auch
nicht okay und jetzt mit von dort
klettern schönen platz machen
aha ich sehe schon ist laut cook das ist
eigentlich das was man nie möchte dass
der von dante rissig wird und trocken
wird aber hier an oberfläche finde ich
jetzt perfekt ich hoffe es verstärkt
sich jetzt noch durch das glätten
[Musik]
nach unten streichen so dass ich einfach
einen schönen rechten winkel bekommen
[Musik]
guck mal wenn ihr hier seitlich
luftbläschen habt dann könnt ihr die bei
der upside down methode nämlich ganz
schön raus streichen
dann kommen die hier oben raus und dann
ist er weg wir müssen sie nicht auf
schneiden so die dritte torte bis dann
schon heftig okay okay diese unperfekt
perfekte torte stelle ich jetzt in den
kühlschrank
ich sage dass im umfeld perfekt weil
jetzt habe ich endlich diese riffe drin
ich glaube ich noch nie so sehr über
freundin adresse gefreut wie hier und
später kann ich wenn davon dann geht es
vielleicht an trocknet im kühlschrank
die torte fertig dekorieren aber das
mache ich wahrscheinlich erst morgen und
jetzt kümmere ich mich noch um die
antwort du mich als stelle
123 wunderbar okay jetzt geht's mit der
torte weiter und zwar ist die gage
wirklich schön fest und am besten nimmt
jetzt eure hände und streicht die garage
schön glatt dann bekommt ihr nämlich
auch den von dungeon glatt in das heißt
hier wirklich über die stellen drüber
und es geht mit einer palette einfach
nicht so ganz gut und ich gucke da auch
immer auf die vorlage damit ich wirklich
die gesichtszüge so gut wie möglich hin
bekomme
[Musik]
immer wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen zeit
habe weil zum beispiel was kühlen muss
kann ich schon mal eine deko herstellen
und jetzt habe ich hier schwarzen
fondant daraus mache ich harrys brille
also jetzt geht es im prinzip erst mal
so richtig los mit der harry potter
torte denn ich muss ja noch die ganzen
deko elemente machen nicht gut der butt
ist schon harry potter aber so alles
andere als ich habe jetzt hier schwarzen
fondant und damit er schön aushärtet wie
blüten passte habe ich hier cmc ein
geknetet das einfach so ein pulver
zellulose dadurch hat jetzt aus ein
bisschen viel genommen wird schnell hart
aber ich jetzt nicht schlimm
und was soll ich jetzt hier 3 mm dick
aus ich hab hier einfach dieser abstand
bringe auf dem ausbau starb ich kann
hier einmal drüber rollen und dann mit
die brille schön gleichmäßig dick
und dann nehme ich jetzt hier einfach
zum ausstechen können zwei kreise
ausstechen und stand den inneren kreis
entfernen
rupps keine blumen
[Musik]
aus dem rest schneide ich jetzt auch die
bügel aus ich habe jetzt hier schon mal
eine saite geglättet die könnt ihr euch
jetzt hier oben an die matte legen und
dann den rechten winkel der bug mathe
oder der silicon mutter einfach benutzen
ich nehme hier eine tankkarte dies
nämlich auch schön gerade und dann
einfach durchdrücken
ich mache noch zwei zum ersatz sonst da
was bricht oder so und das
zusammenkleben der brille mache ich
natürlich erst wenn alles getrocknet ist
jetzt noch alle schön einheitlich zu
schneiden
also der länge nach und spielte jetzt
unten einfach schon bis hin zu zu recht
wie sagt man dann zurecht hier noch das
mittelteil für die brille hier in der
mitte für über die nase das werde ich
auch ein bisschen und dann können die
teile hier schonmal trocknen schokolade
ihnen und schokolade außen ich nehme
jetzt hier schokoladen fondant der
schmeckt echt mega lecker wie stork
riesen ich weiß ja wie die kennt diese
schwarzen bonbons und ich habe es jetzt
hier schon weich geknetet und ich mache
es jetzt so ich gucke immer wieder rüber
weil ich das bild habe auch einen laptop
ich werde zuerst mal hier oben die
kleine spitze machen und dann den rest
über ziehen denn die spitze bei schon
wie so ein absatz also so gefaltet kann
sich hier kurz aus rolf nicht zu dünn
ausrollen damit ihr einfach schön
klappts habt ein bisschen raum habt um
das ganze auch in falten zu legen
gerade sage ich die flasche auf den kopf
und hals über kopf
also jetzt erstmal hält den oberen part
[Musik]
und wirklich schön hier fanden rein
machen also mit den fingern immer ein
bisschen zusammenrücken und dann bekommt
ihr diese leder falten hin dann ein
großes stück vom band
und konnte man sich alles ertasten auge
auge
[Musik]
lege ich einfach den rest so drüber und
schneit dann alle überreste weg es darf
wirklich auch ein bisschen unordentlich
aussehen
hauptsache hinten ist alles zu
und ihr könnt dann sogar mit so einem
kleinen werkzeug eine nathan zeichnung
[Musik]
ich schreibe jetzt hier nochmal die
reste unten zu nur ganz großzügig
ich überlege mir schon mal wie ich unten
diesen hut wie heißt es dann jetzt
botschaft ich weiß ist aber noch nicht
das außen rum da beim hut hin mache
möchte ich ihnen das später wie gesagt
als dritte torte auf die anderen zwei
sätzen und ich nehme jetzt ein torten
retter denn der es schön dünn aber eben
trotzdem stabil
und ich glaube dann sieht man dann
einfach nicht runter ich habe hier
drunter noch das garching bord ich nehme
sie torte hierüber vorsichtig
[Musik]
und hier habe ich noch etwas schoko von
sand und kies außenrum wir krempeln
hutkrempe jetzt kommt die hutkrempe dran
[Musik]
und die naht mache ich jetzt auch wieder
da hinten einfach so und dann einfach
beim torten retter hier abschneiden oder
sogar bis über hängen lassen das ist
glaube ich auch ganz gut aus
[Musik]
und jetzt mache ich noch mal ein langes
band schnell zu und legt hier einmal um
den hut und dann ist da gut erst mal
fertig und kann morgen dann in aller
ruhe schockiert werden das macht am
meisten spaß weil da sieht man wirklich
noch mal so einen krassen effekt also so
sieht das schon finde ich ganz gut aus
aber wenn er statt irrt wird sie damals
aus
[Musik]
dies war es meine lieben das war gut
zumindest für heute erwarte heute ist
nicht alle tage ich komm wieder keine
frage also bis morgen
das räume hier auf machen auch eine
karaoke einheit
dann geht es mir einfach wieder besser
und dann sehen wir uns morgen wieder das
muss ich einmal noch machen wir den hut
zum aufsetzen
aber das machen wir morgen wenn jemand
beim tragen hilft es wahrlich genug
heute ist tag 3 in hogwarts und wir
starten den tag mit apple crumble etwas
gesünder als sonst also wenn ihr jetzt
keinen normalen zucker sondern machen
sondern wirklich frühstücks apple
crumble ich mache das jetzt so nebenher
und dann geht es gleich mit dem hoch
weiter hoch sarah ist nämlich auch
gleich damit der hut fotografiert habe
ich hier schon äpfel und zitronensaft
mitnehmer noch ein
und ich mache das jetzt hier einfach mit
dinkelmehl haferflocken mandeln nüsse
wir sind tom karonga vegan ein stückchen
vegane butter und wissen dass in sirup
dann können nämlich dennis und volkan
auch mit
[Musik]
wir schon gebacken das müsli mit äpfeln
jetzt
jetzt ist das frühstück gleich fertig
und wir machen an dritte weiter jetzt
wird der sprechende hut datiert dafür
habe ich jetzt braune und schwarze
lebensmittelfarbe in pulverform
das ganze wird es nämlich trocken
aufgetaucht wundert euch übrigens nicht
über den wolken hier und über sarah
sollen wir machen gerade noch fotos
direkt zeig dich volker volkan er möchte
nicht erkannt werden v punkt ab und er
möchte nicht erkannt werden genau wir
machen kann auch fotos im katalog für
den nächsten
ok jetzt nehmt ihr die farben ich habe
hier braun und schwarz braun bräuchte
man theoretisch nicht aber ich möchte
das auch immer ganz gerne
und alles was jetzt hier tiefe hat also
die augen der mund die falten werden
jetzt im prinzip schockiert so dass ihr
noch mehr tiefe halt bekommt und ich
starte da immer erst mal sehr vorsichtig
mit der farbe und dann wirklich nur ganz
langsam dunkler werden
so sei und hier in der mitte eher
dunkler und dann nach außen hin wieder
heller werden
und das sieht man jetzt schon ganz gut
das macht schon einen unterschied also
die seite ist jetzt schon schockiert und
die noch nicht sieht man dass man vorne
und ich glaube es macht ihm spaß
sarah ist die styropor helden haben uns
gedacht normalerweise passiert sowas
immer so hinter der kamera aber warum
soll nicht auch sehen was hier ständig
für den wahnsinn herrscht war kann heute
schon und karaoke
jeder der hier arbeitet muss hier singen
denn musik macht uns glücklich
[Musik]
ja irgendwann singe ich noch so sarah
welche menschenfigur bist du
[Musik]
der sprechende hut ist fertig ja ich bin
zufrieden
jetzt habe ich ja den sprechenden hut
gebacken
im film spricht ja auch wirklich
entscheidet ja wer in welches haus kommt
ich probier's mal vielleicht diese
ansprechbar
hallo hallo hallo meine wäsche aus
schokolade vielleicht kann ich ihnen
becken mit einem extrakt ich würde schon
wach werden daran wenn mir das jemand
unter die nase hält
[Musik]
den haben wir in der hölle
ich habe mir gedacht vielleicht kannst
du mir sagen in welches haus ich passen
würde
da muss ich kurz überlegen wenn ich mir
die torten von eben gerade anschaut dann
bist du für mich ein kleiner streber und
gehörst hallo das haus ravensberg laut
den strebern bio ich bin schon fleißig
und ehrgeizig aber ein streber nicht
nett
nein da passe ich nicht rein nicht nein
was gibt es noch dann vielleicht havel
pass da kommen so verträumte hallo sehe
ich aus wie ein träumer
da könnte man doch murat und gummi
hinschicken muss hat im juni zusammen
die zwei machen das haus kaputt aber
streber passt auch nicht beiden dann
lasst auch einen von beiden dort könne
zum beispiel und moral
woran zu früh ist er ja auch übrig dann
bleibt aber für dich nur noch
schlimmeren ins leere wenn da sind noch
die ganzen bösen drin da bin ich auch
nicht hin dann weiß ich auch nicht also
wir haben nur vier häuser dann hast du
wohl in deinem haus in waghäusel bleiben
ok dann bleibe ich da dann schicken wir
denken hier weg und ich bleibe in meinem
haus hier gut maps auch da ich bleib bei
dir helfen werde ich dann essen
jetzt komme ich zu gleis 9 drei viertel
die torte ist ja bereits überzogen und
war über nacht im kühlschrank
ich habe jetzt hier roten von land und
schwarzen denn ich möchte jetzt
backsteine nachahmen bzw sogar richtige
backsteine machen kann
die folgenden maschine liebe männer ihr
teuren frauen einen gefallen wenn ihr
nach dem händewaschen das waschbecken
wieder schön trocken bleibt so und so
und so bei seiner mama nicht bei seiner
freundin er hat keine freundin
ich wollte nur klarstellen ob die macher
jetzt raus damit die ziegelsteine die
backsteine alle gleich dick werden alle
3 mm dick so anstrengend wie das früher
immer alleine gemacht alles alleine und
die kamera und stativ ja nebenher des
geknetet man helfe so eine torte in der
woche gebraucht und dann mache ich es
auch so dass das soll so ein bisschen
wie die wand da hinten also diese
backsteinwand schon sowieso struktur
haben und farbverläufe und jetzt mit
becker stecke ausrollen
das muss jetzt hier gar nicht so glatt
sein denn klinker sind ja auch nicht
glatt daher gebe ich mir da jetzt nicht
so viel mühe das jetzt klar zu machen
jetzt habe ich hier wie gesagt die 3 mm
abstand bringen dann werden sie
gleichmäßig dick sehr gut ich bin stolz
auf dich
wagnis voller sport ich habe jetzt hier
schon geplatzt jetzt sie ist hierüber
denn auf der silicon matra dürft ihr
niemals schneiden und jetzt schneide ich
die klink hat so und ich glaube ich
mache sie wirklich relativ klein so wie
bei mir an der wand also nehme ich jetzt
hier das etikett und schneidet hier die
streifen zu wenn ihr das nicht habe
nehmen die einfach und witze rad oder
lineal zum beispiel das dauert dann halt
nur ein bisschen länger denn hier kann
ich jetzt viel streifen auf einmal zu
schneiden
sie beziehen ein bisschen becker stärke
drauf und ihr könnt auch die platte
gerne antrocknen lassen dann schneidet
sich besser
[Musik]
nachdem du den bug workshop hier bei mir
absolviert rasch kannst du die konditor
der konditormeister macher der
malermeister der maurer und
fitnesstrainer
jetzt mache ich noch den goldenen spatz
dass der hier
nein habe ich mir überlegt um den für
die deko aber nein ich zeige euch wie
ich denn machen
zuerst hatte ich mir überlegt diese
runden pralinen zu nehmen dieser
lindower aber die sind zu klein
also nehme ich jetzt hier die kuchen
reste und bin eigentlich ganz froh dass
wir sie nicht schon aufgegessen haben
ihr könnt zum beispiel auch einfach nur
den schmerz machen als kat kopf ja ich
mache es nicht so viele so schön
zerbröseln
und dann nehme ich gerne an dem ich
jetzt einfach nur so viel dass eine
klebrige masse entsteht
ich sag es schon wieder
ihr könnt auch eine größere schüssel
nehmen bevor sie gekleckert hat hat sie
doch eine größere schulden jetzt hier
schön mit der garage verbinden
das ist nämlich den großen eis
funktionäre und fülle den einmal flach
damit die form das jetzt hier schön zu
einer kugel so rund wie nur möglich
guckt mal wenn ich sehen irgendwas
reinlegt was und eben auch schön rund
ist dann werden sie nicht flach unten
ich habe hier jetzt noch etwas gar
schweiße ganache die erwärmung jetzt
denn das wird jetzt mein vogel material
für die klinke ich bin nur noch an
zauberei machen wer will fleißige
handwerker sehen der muss der sandy
gegen roddick beim 1
der maler streicht die wende
das war falsch wie sein sowie sein da
gas ersetzt die scheiben ein
ja ich habe hier meinen doppelglas mit
wasser perfekt guckte mal so muss
fugenmasse aussehen habe ich etwa
gekleckert sehr gut und jetzt machen wir
eine kamerafahrt es macht mich glücklich
jetzt warten wir mal gesorgt ich hab
mich jetzt mal genau das hat jetzt alles
zwischen uns kaputt gemacht kommt meine
kinder kommt es in zehn menschen
wir sind mittlerweile wie so eine sitcom
das ist so hey willkommen im löffel
gabel egal du kannst noch mal wahr
machen
jetzt habe ich hier also die große torte
und da kommt jetzt ein bisschen
spachtelmasse drauf und durch die kalte
torte zieht es auch gleich an man besser
wäre es jetzt ihr hättet jetzt schon
untergrund für die torte zwar schon auf
einem kickboard die torte hätte die
jetzt auch ohne von dann machen können
aber so ist einfach nochmal geschützter
und ich habe hier oben drauf eben auch
die schicht also da dürfte gerne selbst
entscheiden wie er die machen wollte und
jetzt diese steine ankleben so ein
bisschen versetzt und die zweite reihe
kommt und hier somit ich drüber
dann sieht man so wissel die fugenmasse
raus
ich wollte es ursprünglich darauf malen
aber ich glaube einfacher ist es ich
mache das jetzt mit blüten passte ich
habe nämlich schon blüten passt er
ausgeräumt und lockt hier ganz dünn dass
harry potter logo mache ich auch gleich
und ich glaube dass hier trug ich mir
auch kurz aus und dann kann ich es schön
abmalen ich gucke nur noch wegen
hogwarts express und plattformen ob ich
das auch hin schreibt aber ja ich
schicke das kurz drüber nach oben kann
das mal ausdrücken ich hab nämlich unten
kennt rocker c java
ich habe ich das harry potter logo und
ich versuche jetzt sogar hier drunter zu
legen
ja ganz schön ab pausen und einfach drum
herum schneiden hier guck ich auch noch
ein bisschen
ihr seht das ausgeschnittene das gab
wirklich super aber dafür muss wirklich
die blüten passte oder davon dann
einfach schön lange trocknen ist noch
nicht ganz trocken ihr seht dass es noch
ein bisschen flexibel aber dadurch dass
die oberfläche und die unterseite
angetrocknet ist lässt sich echt gut
schneiden und verzieht sich nicht so das
kann ich jetzt hier noch ein bisschen
antrocknen lassen bzw
ich könnte sogar
ich lasse es noch an trocknen und später
kommt dann gold drüber aber ich mache
das jetzt so dass es nicht komplett
trocknet denn ich will sehr später an
die torte geben
kommt es zur seite und dann mache ich
jetzt noch plattformen neuen drei
viertel
ich mache gerade eine harry potter torte
kennst du harry potter was willst du
machen musst von dann komme ich kann dir
hier die reste geben die kannst du
ausstechen
[Musik]
mehr von don't have to me die lockere
gibt dir oder guck mal los vielleicht
hat er auch ich zeichne jetzt erstmal
mit lebensmittel farbstiften dass hier
alles auf
[Musik]
ich habe mir etwas überlegt ich mache
jetzt hier die schrift schwarz auf weiß
und macht dann noch eine schwarze
umrandung denn weiß auf schwarz ist
bisschen schwierig
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich das hier und nehmen noch
mal ein bisschen pulver um das ganze so
ein bisschen schmutzig zu machen also so
einfach so ein bisschen drüber bruder
das mich ganz so neu aussieht
und da kann ich gleich neun drei viertel
direkt an die torte ankleben mit
essbaren kleber versucht euch die
schönste seite aus die ihr vorne haben
wollt den kleber wirklich sparsam
benutzen der sehr ergiebig die
verteilten dann gern noch ein bisschen
das krasse ist erfreuen nicht mal aus
gemessen ob das passt ich habe das volk
vergessen weil es einfach gucken war
normal weiß ja dass noch vorgetastet
perfekt ich habe zum 68 druck 14 cm
supi das ist das unter stockwerk
ich habe nicht alle angeguckt aber ich
weiß dass der winkelgasse ist wo sich
die steine so ok ja schon trainieren sie
zugeben winkel gas oder verschieben sich
so die steine hier ist jetzt plattformen
934 gleis 9 drei viertel und die
rückseite ist winkelgasse siehst du
passt alles so ich würde sagen sarah
fotografiert wolken und karaoke pause
willst du kannst besser ich kann nicht
so hoch singen
[Musik]
männer
ich kann es nicht
[Musik]
jetzt gleich wieder ab nötig ist
rock your party
[Musik]
new york
jetzt mache ich den goldenen schnitts
weiter denn ich hab ja so angefangen die
kugeln sind schön hart und jetzt nehme
ich hier blüten passte und fondant das
ganze hab ich schon gemischt eins zu
eins nicht zu dünn
denn ich will jetzt die kugel damit
einkleiden und der park wird ist er
drüber gezogen
zum anfang etwas schwer ich wegen den
falten als wirklich so versuchen so
faltenfrei wie möglich hinzukriegen
aber natürlich muss ich an der
unterseite die falten zusammenraffen und
dann zwiebel ich sie einfach weg und
versuchst hier so glatt zu drücken
[Musik]
kugel lege ich jetzt kurz zur seite und
macht schon mal die flügel wenn ihr
fondant und blüten passt er mich dann
könnt ihr es auch wirklich viel dünner
ausrollen
das kommt durch die blüten passte gucke
ich mir kurz die flügel an
ganz oben so rund und dann hinten so ein
bisschen geschwungener ich muss ich
tatsächlich
ja ja der jungs hat nicht unrecht denn
ich arbeite normalerweise immer mit
essbaren dingen in der küche immer
besetzt das einzige mal wo ich wirklich
zaubern muss denn ich brauche jetzt trat
damit ich diese runde hinbekommen
zahnstocher wird nämlich alles kaputt
machen erstmal halbieren
und dann mache ich hier so eine rundung
ich dir helfen so weiter mache ich das
hier so und so
also wieso ein geschwungenes dreieck und
dann nehme ich jetzt kleber wieder den
essbaren es kommt hier oben an den rand
dann kommt ihr da draht rein und wird so
eingewickelt so haben die das bestimmt
bei harry potter auch gemacht also guckt
auf jeden fall dass euer draht
verbissener länger ist und hier schön
flach drücken
der größere geht eigentlich nur weil da
ist ja auch klein und geflügel sind
riesig und jetzt würde ich aber noch
er hat ja auch so sowieso federn dran
dass wir sowieso einschneiden so
eindrücken nicht bis ganz hoch dass es
nicht so ganz zerbrechlich wird aber
schon filigran ich kann sofort im film
requisite machen ich machte
filmrequisiten den goldenen schnitts
und dann kann ich nämlich mit dem pinsel
den kleber hier aufzeichnen
[Musik]
ja ich kenne jetzt so schlecht sitzender
ich muss erstmal runter und mache einen
super querstreifen also ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen da bin ich jetzt nicht so
genau
nur da gucke ich einfach dass es gut
aussieht dass man erkennt was es ist
aber ich mache es nicht jeden streifen
so genau wie sich's gehört
ich habe jetzt hier die brillen teile
und etwas iso multisim
zuckeraustauschstoff der einfach eine
andere schmelz eigenschaft hat also in
anderen schmelzpunkt als zucker
das heißt er schmilzt aber
karamellisiert einfach nicht so schnell
und deswegen ist der perfekt geeignet um
zum beispiel gläser zu gießen oder um
auch ein lebkuchenhaus zusammenzukleben
denn zucker ist einfach schön flüssig
wenn er heiß ist und wird schnell fest
wenn er abgeholt das heißt wirklich
sofort ein ergebnis sofort diese
klebkraft und ich benutze den zucker zum
einen um die gläser zu filmen wenn ihr
könnt sie auch so lassen aber somit nach
scheibe drin sieht chocolat aus und ich
benutze ihn auch gleich um eben das
zusammenzukleben jetzt warte ich eben
besser schnell ist hey ich bin harry
markopolos wangari um liebe user das
heißt liu sei okay ich probier's ich
hoffe das geht hier auf dem wachs papier
ich glaube ich probiere erstmal denn ich
will jetzt nicht auf meinen backpapier
gießen mein backpapier ist nämlich
strukturiert die folie auch eine leichte
struktur ist was schönes glattes habe
zuwachs papier
vielleicht habt ihr auch glatt 4
doch das passiert das jetzt gut aus und
ist jetzt wirklich schön glasklar und
ich probiere es jetzt einfach mal kurz
hier zu gießen
lasst es geschwind aus herten und gucke
ob sie es abläuft
als er war gut dass ich es ausprobiert
habt denn auf wachs papier lebt weiter
damit ist doch meine dauer bartoli jetzt
mal ein bisschen struktur aber dann habe
ich eine struktur gläsern
egal also hier einmal das zwei mal da
kommt es jetzt rein
[Musik]
ich glaube die luftbläschen so weit ist
es wieder kein glas gießen so dass ich
es besser
da hatte ich auch mehr vom glas seht ihr
da ist es richtig schön glatt und hier
nicht denn hier hatte ich zu wenig macht
und die war auch schon ein bisschen zu
kalt
eigentlich von anfang an soll hier so
ein blitz zum schloss jetzt mache ich
hier mit der mittleren torte weiter das
hier wird ja so eine beton optik daher
der risse gefunden
hier habe ich das logo und des
gespräches mit metallic farbenen kupfer
und gold ihr könnt aber auch mit pulver
farben machen also wie ihr wollt ich
mache es bei dass ich nehme jetzt
erstmal hier gold metallic strain
natürlich alles lebensmittelfarben und
da auch darauf achten dass er die dose
so haltet und nicht so denn ansonsten
entweicht das gas die farbe bleibt
drinnen und irgendwann hab da einfach
nichts mehr von ihrem produkt ich bin so
ein bisschen neigen muss ich auch
und hier sieht man braucht wirklich nur
ganz ganz ganz wenig ich nehme jetzt
noch bisschen kupfer drauf das ganze so
ein bisschen alt aussehen so und dann
nehme ich jetzt einen trockenen pinsel
und habe hier noch trockener prüfe
farben in schwarz braun bronze und gold
und damit strukturiere ich jetzt noch
die torte
[Musik]
gefällt das match der fliegt weg da kann
auch gar nicht fliegen der hat keine
flügel dass schnaps kommen jetzt mal den
gold was machen wir jetzt so
er selbst spricht erst mal beim schwatz
die unterseite ein last trocknen und
dann die oberseite und natürlich auch
die flügel bei den vögeln auch erstmal
die rückseite
und nach der trockenzeit dann die
vorderseite und solange räume ich jetzt
auf also wir was ich jetzt mache bitte
ganz vorsichtig machen denn ich nehme
jetzt auch dieses isomalt also den
zucker um die brille zusammenzukleben
und halt jetzt hier das teil in der hand
aber sehr vorsichtig damit ich mich
nicht schon wieder an kaka müll
verbrennen
[Musik]
ich finde die brille darf auch sowieso
so verklebt aussehen denn dieser halt
eben viel im auto los muss ich sagen
und wie gesagt habt ihr den vorteil dass
es wirklich sofort zusammenklebt
[Musik]
und wenn das zucker jetzt gleich
aushärtet steht die brille hoffentlich
alleine ohne metallic screen
ansonsten müssen wir mit alex prix mit
in harry potters geschichten
[Musik]
das kann ich hier das logo auf meine
hand legen vorsichtig ich hab so wachs
papiers dazwischen dann kommen jetzt auf
die rückseite etwas zucker kleber und
ich gebe es hier an die torte
[Musik]
mit dem rest obwohl die technik machen
schaut euch die top techniker hier
rechte und dann legte dieser drauf
gottes muss ich echt mal als krasse
technik benutzen curricula es aussieht
ich so blattgold
ich glaube dass das ganze coolste stelle
im video
[Musik]
volle schwabe trick ich mache mal eine
hochzeitstorte so sarah habe ich jemand
eine so machen hab ich dann auch bei
einer hochzeit singen warum du musst was
drunter seht ihr wie die tat erwischt
die rutschte gleich runde eine universal
untersetzung ein universal- und haben
sich auch schon ziemlich cool oder so
als harry potter fan tutte okay erst am
abend war es zu spät
deswegen habe die torte nicht mehr
fertiggestellt und außerdem konnte jetzt
der staat über nacht noch mal schön
durch kühlen die farbe trocknen
jetzt wird im prinzip nur noch alles
zusammen gesetzt also hier habe ich die
flügel vom platz hier muss ich den draht
etwas kürzen und zwar schon so bis da
silva stocker bricht
ja vielleicht ne zanggasse
testo wenn du was macht schon dann weißt
du eigentlich dass es kaputt geht oder
es trotzdem und sagt ja manchmal würde
man einfach das geht so wie hier die
brille sollte ging nämlich über nacht
kaputt ich aber gar nicht schlimm denn
im film ging harris priller auch kaputt
also klebe ich jetzt einfach zusammen
und macht so ein streifen blöden
passiert dann ist der original wählen
will zumindest im ersten teil der j ich
klebe es einfach jetzt hier zusammen
isomalt klebt alles ja ja ja so kann das
ist gar nicht so einfach
das ist mein eigentum
die werkstoff sonst sich eine andere
frage
warum machen wir die haare brille nicht
einfach komplett kaputt
[Musik]
dann hat er sich halt so sehr darauf
gesetzt dass es sind gar nichts mehr
ging shop ist der ball kam dann für die
motiv torten zuständig der die letzten
drei tage jetzt viel gelernt
die gehört so sah sie nach dem unfall
aus sie müssen wieder reporterin sara
kommen auch in sallys welt läuft nicht
immer alles glatt
das gehört so ihr müsst es nur richtig
vergleichen
ok der goldene spatz du musst jetzt
funktionieren da werde ich jetzt auch
einfach isomalt nehmen hier rein und
steckt dann das ganze ziemlich gerade
rhein sowie bei dem schmerz da hinten
wenn ihr es so macht dann kann es
nämlich wirklich runter krachen
[Musik]
und jetzt mache ich hier nur noch zwei
kugeln drauf das hat nämlich dass da
auch und dann ist es fertig dann kann es
angerichtet
[Musik]
die musst du selber ein stücken vorwärts
und der stadt
aber jetzt müssen noch alle drei
gestaffelt werden nur noch okay jetzt
kann ich die torte stapeln damit jetzt
die oberen torten die untere nicht
eindrücken durch das hohe eigengewicht
müsste jetzt hier unten kleine städtchen
reinstecken schaschlikspieß reichen da
nicht aus ich nehme es gleich rundholz
das habe ich in der garage muss es aber
aus messen ist praktisch wie beim
hausbau sind dass die stützen die dann
die obere etage einfach halten ansonsten
klappt nämlich alles zusammen uns wird
zerdrückt ich mache jetzt hier nehme ich
mir jetzt einmal das maß bin ich aber
noch das garching bot runter
sie können auch auf messen und garagen
dort abziehen aber ich mache das jetzt
hier so dass ein lebensmüder stift also
keine sorge
und jetzt habe ich hier die länge für
die dübel für die untere torte hier
denke ich
sieben stück 1 zentimeter und sechs
stück außen rum und dann messe ich jetzt
gleich noch die höhe der mittleren torte
aus die ist ein bisschen höher da kann
ich auch gleich dübel zu schneiden
[Musik]
wenn ich die torte zu transportieren
würde von a nach b also von hier wo
anders sind
dann würde ich das so machen entweder
vor ort zusammen staffeln oder ihr
stapels jetzt zusammen und klebt aber
nochmal mit garage und dann mache ich
aber meistens so dass ich keine garage
platte darunter habe sondern zum
beispiel eine leicht schaum hatte
denn dann könnt ihr noch von oben nach
unten einmal so einen großen dübel
durchstecken damit die torte nicht
verschoben wird
aber ich würde es eher bevorzugen die
torten einzelnen zu transportieren und
dann zu stapeln
ja manche wissen vielleicht nicht was
von a nach b heißt entschuldigung mache
ich auf facebook
das rot das sprechende weiß habe ich
drauf worum ich das auch nein ich möchte
nach vorne schauen so ja sogar das sagen
willst du bist so lange an der pforte
gearbeitet so lange drauf gewartet sag
ich doch klar dass ich will durch dreh
oder so viel druck aufgebaut
ich hab eigentlich nachts wird größer so
denke ich die ganze zeit was fehlt den
damals so die bremer fans so richtig
kaputt wenn sie da sitzt du schnaps wo
soll da hin auf gut und ich glaube ich
nehme aber noch so ein paar steine und
verbinde sozusagen das unternehmen im
oberen stockwerk vielleicht tue ich
sogar noch ein paar asse dran kleben
[Musik]
kommissar keller sehr mag und samira
etive probieren
ich glaube jetzt wird gerne jeder
zuschauer mit euch tauschen wollen und
einfach diese torte vorschlug
ok also ich habe jetzt gedacht wir
schneiden jetzt einfach mal den hut an
hier
ich habe es trotzdem nicht wie der arme
hoch duca law school ausnahme school
geworden und ich glaube auch ziemlich
lecker der hut 17 echt aus ich dachte
ebenso was chris potter aber ich hab ja
krems stein gebaut
das grundstück bisschen welcher die
torte nicht geklebt habe sie taten es
ist das militär
also hier oben schokolade und in der
mitte habe ich unten filmt mit kirche
und oben weist geschwüre asia markt
gefordert die torte probierst warte ich
muss noch was machen
du bist jetzt harry potter okay weißt du
was kaum
ja das ist das sowieso an der seite von
mir als der einzig wahre harry potter
zeigt sehen und die kratzt manchmal
nadine aber so diesmal sehr und ich
find's cool sein cool so ist auch das
genauso lehrer würden jetzt sagen nicht
dasselbe aber das gleiche
rohrdorf streber lecker schmecker würde
ich mal sagen eigentlich nur eigentlich
ich erwarte aber jetzt muss ich um die
unseren anzuschneiden muss ich natürlich
die obere wegnehmen nicht erst einmal
kurz zur seite
okay da mache ich kurz sauber also zum
anschneiden müsste halt unternehmen und
die stäbe die könnte dann entweder
wegnehmen oder einfach drum rum
schneiden das kann dann auch jeder gast
oder jeder der die torte essen möchte
mit weißer genommen also ein bild machen
da wird das aber weiter stinksauer
[Gelächter]
daneben wird jetzt auch noch runter ich
weiß nichts gemacht hast mit fieber ist
schon das video gesehen noch bevor wir's
geschnitten haben ihr seid die struktur
erkannt wahrscheinlich nicht mehr los
angeles kind durch die weiter vorne
anschneiden dass man das dann vorne
sieht
schalten immer so ne dann machst du so
eine torte und dann zack kaputt sollte
schweinsteiger ist immer so cool gibt es
dann soweit sein
ja man kann zwar guten zu crysis 2 da
sind wir wieder bei unseren videos
[Musik]
samira kennt sich aus
wow das war himbeer oder kerscher kirche
so soll ich euch einfach eine gabel von
jedem geben also das hier ist schott
wurde
dankeschön ich hab auch ne gab ich
glaube so lange hat es ja noch nie auf
dem tortenstück warten müssen und
überlegen sich was war noch mal
schokolade und salzbrezeln und irgendwas
konkretes handeln
alex schokolade
die apple passen ich glaube mein
lieblingsstück ich bitt und die crumble
die sind echt gut darin zog sich jetzt
durch für apple wieder teilweise damit
selbst saftig und das dezente bin ich es
auch gespannt ich klar ich bin so ein
stück mut am besten
und danach ich finde die mitte am besten
ich habe unten und dann oben ja mal
schoko ist halt schock ich will auch
apple crumble am besten aber alle drei
sind gut glaube auch schön saftig würde
man heute ist bei uns freitag
ich habe angefangen am dienstag nur weil
bei uns wir machen die fotos die videos
und alles dauert alles bisschen länger
normalerweise wäre ich auch schon also
locker nach zwei tagen zwei volle tage
hätte ich gebraucht für alles und ich
alles noch super saftig und cremig also
die wird jetzt auch locker noch bis
morgen halten ja echt cool also ich
hoffe dass euch die harry potter torte
gefällt's schreibt gerne in die
kommentare
falls ihr noch weitere ideen habt
schreibt ja auch in den kommentaren wenn
ihr wollt dass ich zum beispiel das buch
nach branche oder keine ahnung welches
motiv schreibt in die kommentare wir
können ja die reporter auch fortführen
wenn es gut ankommt bei euch und
eigentlich wollte ich dass wir mit
aufsätzen
das habe ich schon aber das war murat
als heck wird verbleiben
start der harry und seinem elften
geburtstag geholt hat man gesagt hat
also ist er auch so die motorik oder
tokio vor schluss vergab zwei gesichter
heißt also zwei gesichter hier und hier
ich bin darauf so gut kenne ich mich
nicht aus ich habe nur die tore dazu
gebacken
aber ich glaube ich nehme es mir jetzt
wirklich vor ort die harry potter bücher
zu lesen
und da kannst du sie auch lesen okay
nicht okay also viel spaß beim
nachbacken wobei ich bin schon so die
einzelnen und auch so von den einzelnen
motiven her und ich denke ich rate auch
die videos woche einzeln hoch dass wenn
ihr zum beispiel den tod nach machen
wollt könnt ihr euch das video anschauen
und so weiter ja also ich habe mein
versprechen eingelöst
ich hoffe es gefällt euch natürlich
freuen wenn er das sage ich jetzt glaube
ich zum ersten mal wenn ihr mein video
bewertet und es teilt denn ich hatte
wirklich einen sehr großen druck also
das hat sich über die jahre hinweg viel
druck aufgebaut und ich habe es immer so
vor mir hergeschoben aber ich finde das
ergebnis lässt sich gut sehen alter bis
zur nächsten wahl nur ein nachteil habe
ich ja noch was ist in den schatten
im schnitt sind knochenreste eine rolle
kugel okay ich dachte jetzt auch
harry potter film hat er ja das eine
kind war der schmerz ist auch okay
tochter musste schutz
jetzt machen wir ne fette harry potter
party jetzt kann jeder freunde einladen
und kuchen essen
[Musik]